[Musik]
die drohne gaskrise lässt den dax auf
jahres tief abstürzen der leer gefegte
arbeitsmarkt gefährdet die
inflationsbekämpfung und der bayerische
ministerpräsident markus söder waren vor
allem eiskalten winter wir leben in
dramatischen zeiten anders kann man es
nicht sagen meine gäste am sind die
vorsitzende der fdp-fraktion alice weide
bild politik chef jan wolf schäfer
rechtsanwalt viktor winkler und die fdp
politikerin nicole bauer und mein name
ist lena schon bin ich freue mich sehr
heute abend ihre gastgeberin sein zu
dürfen beim thema heute abend uns für
100.000 handwerker als handwerksmeister
tochter für mich eine sehr erschreckende
zahl bei den arbeitsagenturen sind
150000 offene stellen gelistet der nicht
alle betriebe überhaupt ihre vakanzen
melden der zentralverband des deutschen
handwerks von schätzungsweise rund
250.000 für den handwerkern aus tendenz
steigend wir müssen bei der nachwuchs
und fachkräfte versorgung
schnellstmöglich entgegensteuern ich bin
mir sicher sonst droht uns ein verlust
von wertschöpfung und wohlstand meine
erste frage geht heute als frau bauer
sollte nämlich wissen ob der
fachkräftemangel im handwerk noch ohne
einwanderung zu schaffen ist ich würde
sagen es kann nur mit einwanderung und
zwar mit fachkräfte einwanderung gehen
in unseren arbeitsmarkt und übrigens
nicht nur im bereich der handwerker
sondern auch im bereich der
arbeitskräfte fachkräfte im allgemeinen
es fehlt an allen ecken und enden wie
sehen sie auch an den flughäfen derzeit
am boden personal entsprechend
akquiriert wird aus der türkei und
vielem mehr ich glaube es war auch ein
modernes einwanderungsgesetz in unseren
arbeitsmarkt es braucht aber auch
genauso die stärkung der beruflichen
bildung im bildungssystem sie haben
jetzt auch als fdp angestrebt dass die
ansprache auch englisch die zweite
amtssprache wird was erhoffen sie sich
davon wir haben so viele menschen in
unserem lande nicht glaube einfach dass
es sich wohltuend ist für unser land
dass wir auch in englisch gerade in
behörden auch arbeiten es würde vieles
vereinfachen vieles an bürokratie auch
vereinfacht nun insgesamt mit zweite
möglichkeit geben viele länder machen
sonst vor warum sollten wir nicht auch
diesen weg gehen vor beide würden sie
mitgehen bei frau bauer dass wir
gezielte einwanderung brauchen um das
fachkräfte in den fach mangel besonders
im handwerk was mir sehr am herzen liegt
zu schaffen
ich kann ich kann ihre seite da völlig
verstehen will ich das auch am herzen
ich habe mich viel mit handwerker
kammern unterhalten und die haben noch
ein weiteres problem aufgezeigt und zwar
das hauptproblem in deutschland ist dass
die studiengänge also einmal die
akademische ausbildung die universitäre
ausbildung und daneben die berufliche
ausbildung nicht gleichwertig vom staat
behandelt werden also als beispiel heißt
dass ein philosophie student an der uni
wird wird viel stärker vom steuerzahler
gefördert als jetzt der
maschinenschlosser in ausbildung und
teilweise ist es ja auch noch so dass
sie ihre studiengänge ihre lehrgänge
selbst bezahlen müssen also da würde ich
mir erstmal erhoffen dass wir
diesen weg ist nahe aber dass die
ausbildungswege einfach gleichwertig
auch behandelt werden das wäre schon mal
ein guter schritt die duale
berufsausbildung auch mit auszubauen
würden sie also den meister umsonst
machen der meister kostet heute geld bis
zu 10.000 euro man kann ihn auch in
teilzeit machen der meister kommt nach
der gesellen lehrer würden sie das zum
beispiel dann sagen philosophie
studenten dürfen auch quasi umsonst
studieren also soll der meisterabschluss
auch umsonst zu erwerben sein ich bin
grundsätzlich für für gleichwertigkeit
wenn es heute so ist das der diplom
kaufmann oder der philosophie
masterabschluss
irgendwie nichts kostet umsonst ist ein
semesterticket studienbeiträgen 180 die
wahrheit die wahrheit ist ja es ist ja
nicht umsonst es gibt ja auch kein free
lunch das sind steuerzahlergelder also
wenn man nachher von der ausbildung
profitiert dann kann man auch selbst
teilweise die kosten tragen was ich
einfach sage ist dass die studiengänge
gleichwertig behandelt werden müssen und
diese ausbildungsweg des handwerkers
deutlich aufgewertet werden muss und das
ist gerade nicht der fall und deswegen
haben wir gerade diesen
fachkräfte-mangel vor allen dingen im
handwerk
noch mehr glaube ich dass das muss man
auch mal sagen es gibt es derzeit
bundesweit 1,7 millionen offene stellen
ja und ich glaube das was frau bauer
gerade sagte mit der zuwanderung wir
werden gar nicht drumherum kommen ob wir
jetzt eine gleichheit eine universitäten
und dann im handwerk haben die wären gar
nicht drumherum kommen um die
einwanderung denn wenn wir uns anschauen
wie viele menschen aus dem arbeitsmarkt
in den nächsten jahren in rente gehen
bis 2031 werden das jetzt ein data geben
weil zu wenig junge menschen unten in
den arbeitsmarkt nachwachsen anwälte
haben nach schätzungen des instituts der
deutschen wirtschaft von 5 millionen und
das bedeutete am ende das wir wenn wir
unseren wohl schon einigermaßen halten
wollen um einwanderung gar nicht
drumherum kommen wir kommen nicht drum
herum bleibt statistiken die zahl würde
ich gerne noch einmal einwerfen braucht
die wirtschaft 500.000 einwanderer
jährlich gegen den fachkräftemangel wie
sehen sie das ich wollte sagen als als
aber der klassen kind und auch noch als
einwanderer kind habe ich da schon eine
dezidierte meinung und ein aspekt glaube
ich finde was haben ihre eltern gemacht
wenn sie sagen arbeit herr klassen kennt
also jetzt werden sie lachen mein vater
ist eigentlich opernsänger aber da er
nicht studiert hat und daher die
mindestens die hälfte der zeit seines
lebens mit handwerklichen dingen
verbracht hat erlaube ich mir dann doch
zu sagen ich bin aber der klassen kind
der punkt der mir noch ein bisschen
fehlt einer debatte ist die schule sie
haben ja die das studium angesprochen
man muss doch auch mal sagen rot grün
hat in den ländern systematisch in den
letzten jahrzehnten dieses diese
wunderbare idee des dreigliedrigen
schulsystems zerstört die hauptschule
ist fast schon ein aber alleine thema
kommen wir später nach wien ist ein
bisschen bleiben die einmal bei der
these die ich ja auch mitgebracht hat
heute abend wie sehen sie das sie haben
gesagt sie haben selbst
migrationshintergrund woher kommen sie
rumänien rumänien so wir haben jetzt
hier die these dass die wirtschaft
500.000 einwanderer jährlich braucht
gegen den fachkräftemangel wie sehen sie
da ist wie würden sie sich deutschen als
einwanderungsland vorstellen ich glaube
wir sind schon auf halbem weg dahin ich
glaube dass
das wenn das so ist wir natürlich uns
dagegen nicht sperren können ich glaube
aber dass parallel zu der frage der
einwanderung immer auch die frage sein
muss wie können wir handwerk attraktiver
machen das war ausgangs und ich glaube
da kommen wir immer nur mit
einwanderungen nicht weiter sondern wir
müssen uns auch fragen was diejenigen
die schon bei uns sind was wir bei denen
machen können dass das handwerk
attraktiver wird und das beginnt leider
in der schule und da bin ich leider
wieder bei der hauptschule die idee war
doch wunderbar wer mehr in eine
handwerkliche richtung geht mehr dort
seine talente hat geht auf die
hauptschule wer mehr akademisch
orientierte es geht aufs gymnasium
keines davon ist schlechter als das
andere leider ist es was man isst nicht
mit der einteilung ist schon so also
wenn man sagt derjenige der nicht so
akademisches der soldan berger werden er
geht auf die hauptschule derjenige der
akademische erst mal abitur in seiner
nicht handwerker wenn man ehrlich sagen
wenn man macht den gesellen man macht
den meister dann gründet man sein
eigenes unternehmen da würde ich schon
sagen das abitur auch gar nicht so
schlecht vorher also ist es überhaupt
gut dass so einzugliedern mit dem die
eine schulform ist für akademiker die
andere schulform ist für handwerker oder
er nach talenten gehen wer wie lange auf
welche schule geht auch da habe ich eine
klare meinung ich glaube dass das dass
die unterteilung sehr wichtig ist wir
kranken ja in einem system wo wir es für
selbstverständlich halten dass leute mit
25 erste lebensentscheidung treffen in
welche richtung sie sich bewegen jeder
der unterrichtet jeder der mit mit
jugendlichen arbeitet weiß talente
zeichnen sich ab und je früher diese
talente gefördert werden desto besser
nochmal wer auf die hauptschule geht das
war die ursprüngliche idee ist ja nicht
dümmer und aber auch nicht automatisch
intelligenter als der der aufs gymnasium
geht sondern hat andere talente die dort
gezielter gefördert werden als auf dem
gymnasium
ich glaube genau diese diskussion
brauchte stärker denn je dass wir unsere
kinder wieder nach talenten fähigkeiten
und fertigkeiten fördern fordern und
auch in den entscheidungs raum bieten
für das was sie im leben machen können
und dass wir auch aufzeigen das handwerk
ehrlicherweise kann ich etwas studieren
aber mit dem handwerk habe ich in
goldenen boden weil ich ja stück weiter
ein eigenes unternehmen gründen kann und
aktuellen der jetzigen situation bei dem
enormen handwerker mangel unglaubliche
entwicklungsmöglichkeiten habe also ich
glaube dass diese alte these dieses
akademie sieren als entweder der
akademiker oder das handwerk ein ende
finden muss sondern vielmehr wieder nach
den fähigkeiten und fertigkeiten unsere
kinder gefördert und gefordert werden
müssen und das beginnt aus meiner sicht
schon bei der für mint bildung ehrlicher
war denn das ist aus meiner sicht der
schlüssel dazu dass eben kinder die
vielleicht aus elternhäusern kommen wo
sie keinen bezug dazu haben den bezug
finden und für sich den weg finden wir
die schulbildung reden wir später noch
jetzt können wir erstmal zur these von
frau weil und wenn ich das noch sagen
darf weil mein vater ist ja
handwerksmeister ich finde handwerker
verdammt sexy und ziemlich sollten viel
mehr menschen in deutschland machen und
damit gehen jetzt weiter
haben sie auch recht
[Gelächter]
also meine these am heutigen abend die
die die bitte
die
also ich soll doch in die kamera
reingucken oder nicht wieder tun einfach
sprechen ja genau eigentlich geradeaus
gucken wir haben jetzt begreifen kamera
fehler vor hinaus gucken ja weil sie
hatten gerade irgendwo anders hin
gezeigt
also
die
gesamte energiepolitik der
vorgängerregierung als auch jetzt der
ampel führt uns in einem desaster die
steigenden
gaspreise die jetzt darauf
zurückzuführen sind dass und
energiepreise auf die auf den krieg in
der ukraine
das ist natürlich nicht der einzige
grund
der grund warum die energiepreise durch
die decke gehen also ich rede hier von
sprit ich rede von energiekosten liegt
natürlich daran dass wir eine völlig
verfehlte energiepolitik betreiben
wir bauen auf die erneuerbaren energien
das ist ein flotter strom wir haben
sonst alles abgestellt an
konventionellen kraftwerken
atomstrom kohlekraft also die gesamte
konventionelle energie ist abgestellt
aber dabei brauchen wir wenn wir dunkel
flauten haben beispielsweise also wenn
es dunkel ist und kein wind bläst müssen
wir das über konventionelle kraftwerke
aufwand das ist nicht der fall hier wird
weiter an der schraube gedreht einseitig
seit 2011 wird hier ein kraftwerk nach
dem anderen abgestellt dabei müssen wir
doch eigentlich einen ausgeglichenen
energiemix haben der die energie sicher
und vor allen dingen auch günstig macht
und jederzeit verfügbar
und ich möchte auch da ganz klar sagen
es macht unsere industrie kaputt die
unternehmen sind nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig stichwort
handelsbilanzdefizit erstmalig nach
vielen vielen jahren und vor allem
schlägt es auch die bürger durch warum
ich es absolut unfair finde und völlig
abgehoben hierüber durch dauern zu zu
diskutieren und heitz dauern das problem
nicht doch ganz woanders und das problem
liegt daran
oder liegt darin dass wir überhaupt gar
keine ausgeglichene strategische
langfristige
strukturpolitik in der energiewirtschaft
haben wir ziehen den stecker dem
industriestandort deutschland und wir
sollten den sonderweg deutschlands der
einmalig ist in dieser welt im übrigen
kein anderes land bestreitet den sondern
wie deutschland sollten wir unbedingt
beenden und dementsprechend auch wieder
energiesicherheit sorgen die auch
bezahlbar ist
kohle atomkraft sagen gerade darüber
gesprochen beim ausstieg der läuft das
ist richtig der kernkraft ausstieg der
kohleausstieg der wird jetzt forciert
die kritik die sie machen glaube ich die
ist aber ein bisschen scheinheilig frau
weiter denn ich glaube dass wenn die afg
in der regierung gewesen wäre die
abhängigkeit die wir sehen
beispielsweise von russland mindestens
genau so hoch wenn ich sogar noch größer
gewesen wäre wenn ich überlege dass
heute die afg fraktion im landtag von
mecklenburg vorpommern
einen antrag eingebracht hat wonach nord
stream 2 also dieser umstrittene
gaspipeline mit dem gas aus russland ans
netz gehen soll wo wir doch gerade sehen
in welcher situation wir sind dass putin
uns das gas nach und nach ab dreht dann
ist das geradezu schizophren was da
heute in mecklenburg vorpommern passiert
ist das gegenteil dessen glaube ich was
sie eigentlich jetzt gerade kritisiert
haben was sie sicherlich zum teil auch
zu recht kritisiert haben euch sage mit
in die afg an der regierung gewesen wäre
etwas mit bestimmt hätte können was sie
zum glück nicht gemacht hat dann säßen
wir heute mindestens in dem gleichen
tiefen loch wenn ich sogar sehr es noch
schlimmer aus
wir sind für einen ausgeglichenen
energiemix warum werden hier
konventionelle kraftwerke wie jetzt
schon über ein jahrzehnt abgestellt wo
wir doch genau diese ausgeglichenheit
braucht ein energiemix mit noch stärkere
abhängigkeit so ist er habe ich gerade
nein doch ganz klar nein ich habe gerade
noch zeit sagt genau genau diese hatten
ja natürlich sind ja wir wollen noch
mehr gastfreundliches land sind wir wenn
ich aus reden da gerne natürlich sind
für sind wir für eine hinzu schaltung
von nord stream zwei natürlich wir
wollen doch das gas weiterhin beziehen
weil ein gas- oder ein öl-embargo doch
gar nicht den russen schadet es schadet
nämlich uns den europäern und
vornehmlich den deutschen die russen
machen folgen ist das machen sie bereits
jetzt das was sie nicht an die europäer
liefern liefern sie an drittländer an
china und indien das machen sie jetzt
schon mit dem öl events mit dem gas
machen das heißt wir schaden uns doch
damit selbst wir schaden dem verbraucher
wir schaden unseren unternehmen aber
jetzt doch mal dazu wenn wir in der
regierung gewesen wäre dann hätte es
diesen ganzen diesen ganzen verfahrens
überhaupt gar nicht gegeben warum
schalten wir co2 arme kernkraftwerke ab
warum wird nicht in forschungs und
entwicklungsleistungen in neuartige
reaktor techniken investiert thorium
reaktor es beispielsweise ist gerade das
ist eine deutsche technologie ist gerade
in china ans netz gegangen also letztes
jahr ist es schon gewesen ich gerade
aber das sind einfach solche punkte wir
verpassen den anschluss und wir gehen
als deutschland den einzigen sonderweg
und wir sind völlig abhängig die politik
hat uns komplett abhängig vom ausland
gemacht wurden so dass wir wollen dass
wir etwas wie nein eben nicht
doch wir haben die ganze zeit ja so
schon gas moment mal ich rede aber auch
von kernkraft und ich rede auch von
kohlekraftwerken wir hätten diese
kernkraftwerke niemals abschalten dürfen
um vor allen dingen jetzt ist das doch
nur noch schadensbegrenzung das kriegen
wir gar nicht mehr eingefangen die
energie werden da hat uns doch abhängig
vom russischen gas gemacht das haben die
vorgängerregierung von neuss wegen sind
die regierung noch abhängiger machen
wir müssen auf die kernkraft weiterhin
bauen und wir laufen hier völlig blind
in eine völlig verquere situation ein
und das was wir brauchen ist eine
ausgeglichenheit in eine sachliche
diskussion über unsere energieversorgung
ein industriestaat wie deutschland kann
doch überhaupt gar nicht vom flattr
strom abhängig sein wir haben uns auch
von atomstrom und kohlekraft aus
atomstrom aus frankreich von kohlekraft
aus pohlheim ist doch völlig abhängig
gemacht also das ist doch etwas was von
vorne und hinten gar nicht aufgeben wir
brauchen eine strategische lösung die
strategische lösung sieht so aus dass
wir unsere energieversorgung smeekes
diversifizieren aber wenn sie weiterhin
für nord stream zwei sind dann muss man
ja auch sagen wenn wir weiterhin dafür
sind als nation tolerieren wir dann
nicht auch den angriffskrieg und sagen
wir brauchen putin gar nicht zu
bestrafen das ist völlig in ordnung was
er mit der ukraine macht fasching wir
haben ganz sachlich gesehen wir haben
überhaupt keine andere wahl wir sind auf
das russische gas angewiesen wir haben
überhaupt gar kein kompliment um das in
irgendeiner art und weise zu
kompensieren das alles was ihr auch sage
ja so einer politik geredet wird das
spricht doch das eigentliche problem gar
nicht an wir können das russische gas
gar nicht kommt
komplimentieren das geht nicht über
flüssiggas weil es gar nicht von der
menge ausreicht und wir überhaupt gar
nicht die lng terminals haben der erste
wird der 2026 fertig dann schiefergas
das muss erst vor gericht werden
aber weil das
wurde in der vergangenheit und da gibt
es sicherlich punkte auch beim thema
kernkraft das haben wir hier bei bild
ohnehin schon lange immer wieder gesagt
dass das ein fehler war muss man ja
fehler die gemacht wurden stichwort
abhängigkeit vom russischen gas jetzt
nicht noch potenzieren dem man sagt und
jetzt mache ich noch abhängiger wir
erleben ja gerade was passiert wenn man
sich von putin abhängig macht das ist
eine katastrophe ich weiß ihre partei
sieht das anders sie ist ja auch gegen
waffenlieferungen an die ukraine aber
das muss man doch glaube ich erkennen
dass abhängigkeit in welche richtung
auch immer aber besonders zu russland
das schlimmste ist was einem westlichen
land in der eu gerade passieren kann
also ich glaube so weit sind wir alle
das erkennen wir glaube ich auch alle
dass das eine katastrophe ist ja aber
genau die ursache die muss man ja auch
benennen und die ursache ist die
energiewende politik die hier seit 2011
betrieben wird das ist ein ganz großer
fehler ich habe nichts anderes gesagt
und das zweite ist wir können das gas
doch garnicht komplementieren wir können
wir können es nicht ausgleichen wenn wir
jetzt mit der keule ankommen und für
mich steht das interesse der deutschen
bevölkerung und europas im vordergrund
das andere ist ist erstmal sekundär wenn
uns gesagt wird also jetzt habt ihr zu
frieren jetzt machen wir hier nochmal
eine rationierung da das reicht doch
erstmal überhaupt nicht außen worüber
diskutieren wir wir müssen doch
weitsichtig über eine strategische
energiepolitik reden die überhaupt
imstande ist den industriestandort
deutschland zu versorgen das war doch
vor 2011 nie ein thema und plötzlich ist
es ein thema wo alle konventionellen
kraftwerke abgeschaltet wurden und mein
punkt ist einfach das ist unseriös das
ist hochgradig unseriös es macht unsere
unternehmen wettbewerbs unfähig im
internationalen markt und es lässt die
energiepreise für die bevölkerung durch
die decke gehen wir reden hier über über
eklatante existenz risiken die ich hier
ansprechen möchte und da brauchen wir
einfach eine weitsichtige pragmatische
auch da gebe ich ihn ja auch recht aber
wir brauchen eine pragmatische politik
die einfach sagt okay wir können das
nicht kompensieren
wir brauchen eine sind wir sind auf das
gas geben angewiesen also um es einmal
zu verstehen sind wenn sie herr scholz
werden sagen sie jetzt bundeskanzler
würden sie sagen so wir machen jetzt 92
und machen weiterhin geschäfte mit
russland und dann sollen den russen dann
geben wir den halt die ukraine am besten
und dann war es das die sanktionen sind
völlig wirkungslos sie schaden den
russischen riesen schaden vornehmlich
den europäern und vor allen dingen
deutschland weil wir das russische gas
brauchen wir können es eben nicht
ersetzen das ist das erste also die
sanktionen sind schädlich nicht für die
russen weil die russen erst mal das
angebot verkürzt haben dadurch sind die
preise gestiegen also aufgrund dieser
preiselastizität haben die russen ja
sogar mehr verdient als vorher also das
heißt wir haben sogar eine
kontraproduktive sanktionspolitik und
das zweite ist fasching wenn sie mich
das noch ganz absagen lassen ist dass
die russen wenn sie sagen also wenn ihr
euer so wenn ihr unser gas und öl nicht
haben wollte dafür kaum was eigentlich
gelesen und dann verkaufen was an die
inder wie es bei dem öl jetzt schon
passiert was machen die inder die
verkaufen das öl zu einem vielfachen
preis wieder an europa zurück also dass
das schon alles das sind natürlich im
leben ist bekannt der auch schon bei
bild berichtet die frage ist dann die
man ganz klar sagen es gibt auch genug
wirtschaftsweise und ökonomen experten
sagen die sanktionen werden in russland
auch noch später die wirkung zeigen sie
haben ja auch schon wirkung gezeigt also
dass sie gar keine wirkung zeigen da
stimmt jetzt nicht russland stellt sich
jetzt auch schon auf eine
kriegswirtschaft 1 es ist also keine
keinerlei wirkung der sanktionen ist das
ist ja einfach ein falls fact frau beide
das stimmt ja einfach nicht also nicht
er sich für jede sank somit aber das ist
einfach nicht die wahrheit das ist
keinerlei wirkung zeigt und die russen
eigentlich besser dastehen als zuvor als
ich mal sowas stehen also was nur ganz
ja nur ganz kurz was das was das gas und
öl embargo anbelangt da darauf haben wir
ja gerade rekurrieren ist es in der tat
so dass die sanktionen kontraproduktiv
ich habe über die anderen sanktionen
überhaupt gar nicht gesprochen wenn sie
da über zahlungen die ihm reden klar ist
das schädlich natürlich so schädlich
aber gerade sind wir bei einer
energiepolitik da ist es einfach so
russland verkauft einfach an drittländer
ab so und dadurch dass das angebote nach
europa verkürzt oder gehen die preise
nach oben das heißt wir schauen uns
nochmal doppelt und dadurch dass nur
noch mal abgewertet ist erhöhen sich
nochmal zusätzlich die importpreise also
wie das ist ein schuss ins knie ich sag
jetzt einfach mal der russen sind zwei
schüsse in die knie der deutschen also
ich finde das völlig unseriös wenn sie
mit gehen sie also auf jeden fall im
ersten schritt sicherlich haben durch
das thema öl embargo die russen erstmals
öl preis verdient und sie hatten ja
höhere einnahmen das braucht man gar
nicht zu leugnen aber die sanktionen
waren ja nicht nur einseitig sie haben
ja auch die transaktionen betroffen den
ausschluss aus dem swift-abkommen die
ganze thematik ist einfrieren der
reserven die hierzulande sind der
russischen zentralbank und vieles mehr
es wird sogar so weit dass selbst die in
russland mittlerweile die frage sich
stellt wie man zahlungsfähig bleibt wie
man den zugang zu high tech produkten
hat das thema aus vor verbote
beispielsweise von hat mittlerweile ist
es so dass mechaniker aus flugzeugen die
ehemaligen bauteile ausbauen um sie dann
in andere flugzeuge einzubauen um die
dann überhaupt funktionsfähig zu machen
es werden dort wieder fahrzeuge
produziert wie der motto wird der sei in
den 80er jahren früher produziert wurde
der keinerlei technik beinhaltet außer
nur das vorankommen des autors all diese
punkte spielen eine unglaubliche rolle
und sehr wohl hat vielleicht russland
den ersten schritt für sich ein benefit
gehabt aber im zweiten schritt schadet
es russland enorm und ich glaube auch
nur deshalb fand er fängt jetzt auch
putin an zu handeln in anderen bereichen
weil er aufzeigen möchte dass es selbst
wohl in der bedrohlichen gefahr ist
nämlich auch das wirtschaftssystem in
russland sowie es vorhanden ist in
irgendeiner weise demnächst auch nicht
mehr so standhalten wird das ist die
thematik deshalb wir haben niemals als
regierung nur eines ein embargo oder
eine funktion gemacht es war immer ein
mix von verschiedenen punkten und
wirtschaftspolitik volkswirtschaft
funktioniert ja auch im mix von
verschiedenen
werkzeugen und dann gibt es eine
entsprechende
handlungsmöglichkeit frauchen sie sehen
mich noch mehr hin und herrutschen also
ohnehin schon dass ich etwas sagen
ja dass das merke ich mir vielleicht als
der einzige an diesem tisch der mit
sanktionen ja sein täglich brot verdient
darf ich vielleicht ganz kurz was dazu
sagen und
es fügt sich durchaus einen das was sie
sagen ist ja nicht falsch aber es ärgert
mich so sehr dass wir nicht begreifen
alle miteinander das war halt bis jetzt
nischenthema was sanktionen eigentlich
sollen zunächst mal sind die sanktionen
über die wir hier sprechen eu-recht
bedeutet die eu sagt ihr alle meine
mitbürgerinnen und mitbürger innerhalb
der eu soll es bestimmte dinge nicht
mehr tun bestimmte vermögen sollen
eingefroren seien bestimmte ausfuhren
sollen nicht mehr stattfinden das ist
zunächst mal das rechtliche was hier zu
sagen ist und das funktioniert
funktioniert übrigens in deutschland
aber es ist eine schändliche dabei ist
vielleicht einen tisch bekannt aber
immer höhere nicht gerne ihre vorlesung
mutationen hirschmann sie gerne weiter
haben verpassen das beste
zunächst mal geht es also darum dass
innerhalb der eu bestimmte dinge nicht
passieren soll das tun die sanktion
insoweit sind die sanktionen wirksam
derweil immer so getan wird der einzige
sinn der sanktionen ist drüben in moskau
irgendwas zu erreichen so das ist das
erste das zweite ist dass sie für
frieden sorgen solange sanktionen
besprochen werden wird krieg nicht
besprochen sanktionen sind ein mittel
des friedens auch darüber wird nie
gesprochen das heißt wir tun so als
wären sie das komplette äquivalent zu
einem angriff mit truppen und wir sagen
ja das ist ja nicht so wirksam wie ein
militärischer angriff ja natürlich nicht
es ist ein ersatz für einen
militärischen angriff also das sind so
ein paar sachen glaube ich die wir bei
der frage was sollen sanktionen was
müssen sanktionen beachten und wenn ich
das noch sagen darf wir sind
schlusslicht in europa in der
durchsetzung der sanktionen wir reden so
viel darüber sommer das sanktionieren
sommer dies funktionieren da ist auch
viel dazu zu sagen aber das was wir
haben müssen wir doch zunächst einmal
überhaupt durchsetzen und anwenden und
deutschland ist beim einfrieren zb
schlusslicht ist in vielen anderen
bereichen schlusslicht und auch darüber
müssen wir irgendwann reden vielleicht
nicht unbedingt heute warum ist es so
warum es ausgerechnet deutschland so
schlecht und um die antwort gleich mit
zu geben es hat gar nicht mit bösem
willen zu tun und irgendwelche
lobbyarbeit schon irgendjemanden sondern
es hat was mit airways zu tun es ist
einfach noch nicht auf dem schirm das
bmw k ist nicht so weit vorne bisher im
sanktions thema die länderpolizeien die
die sanktionen zur zeit anwenden müssen
können das nicht woher sollen die armen
dessen können also da müssen wir was tun
kommen wir jetzt eine frau bauer und
auch der atomkraft ist ja auch ein thema
was dort schon sehr bewegt in diesen
tagen ja auf jeden fall ich bin davon
überzeugt dass deutschland tatsächlich
einen energiemix braucht nicht nur die
erneuerbaren aber auch und der wird
genau in dieser
regierungswoche in dieser sitzungswoche
vor der sommerpause auch das eeg
beschlossen wo wirklich die erneuerbaren
einen schub bekommen entbürokratisierung
auf dem weg kommt aber wir brauchen
zugleich natürlich auch grundlastfähige
energie die atomkraftwerke wir haben
noch drei am netz deshalb kann ich da
der verwaltung nicht ganz so recht geben
es sind noch drei am netz wie
beispielsweise isar 2 in niederbayern
das ist eines der modernsten und
sichersten
atomkraftwerke die wir in deutschland
überhaupt haben doch sicher ist sicherer
wieder so manche europäische
atomkraftwerke
und genau deshalb ist es auch notwendig
die diskussion über kernkraft zu führen
einer verlängerung drei bis fünf jahre
auch zuzustimmen und vor allem auch die
forschung in diesem bereich weiter
voranzutreiben wir wissen nicht was in
zehn jahren in 15 jahren in 20 jahren
möglicherweise die technologie sein wird
aber eines wissen wir sicher von der
bundesnetzagentur dass wir keine
ressource in unserem netz verzichten
können um grundlastfähig zu sein um ein
stabiles netz zu haben und vor allem um
versorgungssicherheit bezahlbarkeit und
verfügbarkeit gewährleisten ich bin ich
gespannt ob robert habeck hier gleich
anruft und sagt mensch das war ja toll
aber das war es jetzt mit der koalition
also sie haben ja ein problem sie sind
für die das weiterlaufen von
kernkraftwerken als fdp als fdp
politikerin und da haben aber zwei
koalitionspartner die das auf keinen
fall wollen und was passiert jetzt
sicherlich ich bin nicht die einzige
mittlerweile in der fdp es haben sich ja
zahlreiche kolleginnen und kollegen auf
der portugall
ersetzt eine von drei bis fünf jahren
entsprechend es sich dazu bewegt ich
glaube es wir werden die um die
diskussion nicht drum herumkommen denn
am ende ist es die frage wie viel gas
wird aktuell verstromt und nachdem
deutschland beispielsweise größere
strommengen nach frankreich liefert weil
dort die akw es aktuell nicht am netz
sind müssen wir versuchen dass wir so um
möglichst wenig strom also aus dem gas
bereich überhaupt verstromen und deshalb
ist es so unglaublich notwendig auch
über den winter hinweg neben dem
sicherlich zu sensibilisieren im energie
verbrauch aber nicht vorzuschreiben wie
wohnungen geheizt werden können wie
energie verbraucht werden können wir
haben heute erst in der presse verlesen
können dass es mittlerweile vermieter
gibt die entscheidend wann es warm
wasser gibt und wann es keines gibt all
das ist natürlich notwendig aber diese
regierung hat sich ausgezeichnet in
letzten wochen doch pragmatisches und
schnelles handeln gehört aber dass es
ziemlich bebt auch zwischen den parteien
und auch zwischen den vorsitz des ich
würde mal sagen es ist allgemein so dass
die ampel ist sicherlich ein
regierungsbündnis ist wo verschiedene
mainz war kein hansen fahrrad oder
zusammenkommen es war keine liebesheirat
aber es haben tragen jetzt verantwortung
für unser land wir haben corona bekommen
wir haben den krieg in der ukraine
angezettelt von putin bekommen und die
bürgerinnen und bürger messen die ampel
jetzt an handlung aber frau bauer man
ganz einfach ganz konkrete auch
karl-heinz einmal ganz konkret denn sie
können nicht an 30 dezember sagen so wir
lassen die drei männer einfach jetzt
noch weiter laufen dafür brauchen sie
die brennstäbe die müssen organisiert
werden und es gibt ein zeitfenster was
ich schließt also das ist möglicherweise
ende dieses monats mitte des nächsten
monats ist dieses zeitfenster
geschlossen das heißt bis dahin muss
eine entscheidung fallen richtig oder
falsch also ich gebe ihnen daten grenzt
rechten entscheidung muss natürlich
fallen aber es gibt mittlerweile
betreibe ich habe dieser zwei
beispielsweise schon genannt sie können
problemlos über den winter hinweg uns
mit strom versorgen und dann erst in
eine reduzierte leistung fahren
natürlich müssten die um sicher zu gehen
dass wir auch im april mai juni nächsten
jahres entsprechend versorgungssicher
aufgestellt sind entsprechend die jetzt
die bestellungen machen deshalb ist es
auch so notwendig dass wir jetzt darüber
diskutieren wie ampel daran scheitern
und ein alter eine entscheidung treffen
ob die ampel daran scheitern wird und so
wie sie auseinanderbrechen an der frage
was würde ich jetzt sagen das müssten
sie jetzt unsere minister fragen sollen
entsprechende frage sie hessen für mir
ist es wichtig dass ich mich für die
bürgerinnen und bürger aber auch für die
unternehmen in unserem land einsetze und
dass sich pragmatische vorschläge dann
wären sie wahrscheinlich eine niederlage
erleben weil es bis mitte august bis
ende august die rote und grüne wollen
das nicht die ja aber die frage stellt
sich ja nicht heute gab es hier
beispielsweise aus der eu ganz klare
aufforderung deutschland sollte nicht
mehr überlegen ob sie willens sondern
entsprechend handeln das hat der
innenminister
entsprechend auch geäußert ganz klar
deutschland muss handeln es gefährdet
auch die sicherheit europa im bereich
der energieversorgung deshalb glaube ich
wird sich die situation verändern und
wir sind im gasbereich beispielsweise an
dem punkt dass manche turbinen gar nicht
im netz sind warum weil man sie auch
bewusst außerhalb des netzes aktuell
hält obwohl firmen im land
diese komponenten auch liefern könnten
und zwar problemlos weil sie auf lager
legen all das müssen wir berücksichtigen
und die große wartung im bereich des gas
ist kommt ja erst noch am 11.7 soll es
soweit sein und dann ist die frage geht
nord stream 1 wieder ans netz so wie
geplant oder nicht und dann stellt sich
die frage natürlich den verstromung des
den verstummten anteil an gas kann ich
dann nicht mehr aus dem gas nutzen wir
wissen aber auch dass unsere nachbarn
abhängig sind bei ihre kraftwerke
aktuell die sicherheitsanforderungen
nicht bedienen und wie schon mal bauer
kurze antwort als bürgerin frage ich
mich wirklich wie hoch ist denn jetzt
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass die
regierung diese drei atomkraftwerke sie
kriegen ja viel mit im bundestag nicht
nur die minister kriegen für mit sie
bekommen auch viel mit also wie hoch ist
denn die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
wirklich immer bei villach gefordert von
der politik hat übrigens von sehr vielen
lasst die weiler laufen wie wo ist denn
die wahrscheinlichkeit dass es klappt
ich würde sagen die wahrscheinlichkeit
dass es notwendig wird ist hoch und die
diskussion muss jetzt geführt werden in
der ampel aber auch im parlament und wir
gehen jetzt dann in der sommerpause aber
nach der sommerpause müssen wir diese
entscheidung verstehe dass sie mir
ausweichen es sei ihnen gestattet ich
frage jetzt mal frau weile wie sehen sie
die wahrscheinlichkeit und vor allem
wird die ampel daran scheitern na gut
also eigentlich sollte ja die ampel da
überhaupt keine probleme haben weil
kernkraft wurde ja selbst von der eu als
eine grüne energie form als eine co2
arme energieformen erklärt also
dementsprechend sollte da eigentlich
auch er habe überhaupt keine probleme
damit haben die kernkraftwerke am netz
zu lassen die gerade abgeschalteten die
3 es waren ja mal irgendwie vor einigen
monaten ja noch sechs auch wieder mit
ans netz zu nehmen und vor allen dingen
dann eben auch die kernenergie weiter
auszubauen aber habe und das glaube ich
schon so da kann ja nicht die fdp gar
nicht mitgehen seine idee ist ja nicht
über kernkraft zu kompensieren sondern
über kohlekraft und kohlekraft ist ja
nun wirklich extrem co2 wie sage ich
jetzt mal also dass ein grüner jetzt auf
die idee kommt irgendwie die
kohleverstromung da auch mit zu
verlängern stadt kernkraft also das
passte wirklich überhaupt gar nicht mehr
sagen jetzt auch frau beide machen wir's
mal das ist natürlich eine zweck
heiraten ich glaube sie haben das ja
auch eben schon so gesagt das war ja
keine heirat so aus liebe und
pragmatismus
ich denke mal da wir immer noch sich
lange aneinander klammern somit all den
widersprüchen die diese koalition der
zweifelsohne hatten dementsprechend
bauen die parteien ja auch ab spd und
fdp die einzigen die davon auch
profitieren sind die grünen schaden weil
er neben milla fd weil auch nicht so gut
ja gut aber wir sitzen ja auch nicht in
der regierung schade eigentlich aber wir
reden ja auch sagen
sie was das ist das was ich sagen muss
ich sein und nicht dick macht schuldigen
sie dass es nicht schade wenn man sich
gerade in letzten parteitag anschaut
wenn man sich anschaut dass ihre die vom
verfassungsschutz als verdachtsfall
eingestuft wird dass teile ihrer partei
beispielsweise thüringen als
rechtsextrem eine rechtsextremistisch
eingestuft werden dann glaube ich muss
man mit fug und recht sagen in diesen
demokratischen land ist es eigentlich
ganz gut dass die afg oder sogar sehr
gut dass die afg nicht
in der regierung sitzt und sie kommen ja
sehr cremig und schaut man darüber aber
ehrlicherweise sie sind chef in einer
partei die gespicktes mit nazis das muss
man immer wieder deutlich sagen ganz
klar der name hocke ist nur ein wenn man
sich an der basis umhört und plötzlich
heißt es der herr keilwitz rechts
rechtsextrem ist soll am liebsten wieder
zurück in die partei in teilen wird das
in ihrer pakete diskutiert dann ist das
glaube ich etwas wo wir am ende als
demokratisches land froh sein können
dass ihre partei nicht in der regierung
ist als er schäfer ich finde das ja sehr
schön dass sie jetzt hier auch die ganze
klaviatur des verfassungsschutzes
spielen ein inland gehalten wie du noch
mal wissen ein ja aber was ist der
verfassungsschutz der verfassungsschutz
ist ein inlandsgeheimdienst der von den
regierungsparteien mit besetzt ist zur
verunglimpfung der opposition so und die
afg also der auftrag ja ehrlicherweise
jetzt will ich doch lagarde oder den
schuldigen
die meisten na wie das habe ich bei ihm
auch nicht gesagt ist aber und der
verfassungsschutz ist doch überhaupt gar
keine unabhängige beratung über die wir
jetzt reden und diesen schuh werde ich
mir sicherlich nicht für meine partei
anziehen wenn den schulen sind jetzt
genau die neckische oder welchen schuh
den schule denen sie mir gerade an
ziehen wollten das ist völlig an den
haaren herbeigezogen
extrem ist ach wissen sie also im
schuljahr habe sagt halbe ist
rechtsextreme sie haben noch reale
probleme auf der straße ja die leute in
der sie wolle jetzt erst doch überhaupt
nicht und ich werde ihnen sagen ich
werde ihn einst profi zahlen dieses
ganze negative fremming von der afg von
der alternative für deutschland wird auf
dauer nicht durchhaltbar seien sie mal
den wahlergebnissen wird nicht nur ich
haltbar sein also aber das muss man
sein in ihrer partei aber weiter
schwierig haben irgendwo problemlöser
und die problemlöser sind langfristig
wir und da sind wir nicht mehr
wegzudenken daran werden sie sich
gewöhnen müssen er wegen derselben tat
gesagt dass die aussage juristisch
falsch war was meinen sie mit juristisch
falsch ja also natürlich ist das
politisches
politischer ausdrücke ist es nicht
unabhängig der verfassungsschutz ist wie
jede andere behörde natürlich auch
insoweit nicht unabhängig ist das eher
weisungsgebunden ist die große aufgabe
und der mehrwert des verfassungsschutzes
in unserer demokratie ist nicht dass er
unabhängig ist sondern dass er versucht
darauf zu achten dass nur diejenigen
kräfte in dieser demokratie
grip und halt bekommen die auch
demokratisch legitimiert den ersten
vorstufe zur erklärung des
bundesverfassungsgerichts das nehme ich
eine partei daneben verboten gehört also
das wollte ich nur sagen insofern geht
es hier nicht um unabhängig oder nicht
und die darstellung es handelt sich
sozusagen um eine behörde die von der
regierungsparteien gesteuert ist ja
jetzt von der cdu aber jede vorher
eingesetzt aber sie wissen dorffest
innenministerin also was war denn dann
verweise von uns beiden hat ja nur einer
jura studiert aber sie wissen doch auch
dass jede behörde eingebunden ist
natürlich in den staatsaufbau jede
behörde
das bafa berichtet dass bmw k gmbh kann
den bafa weil wir bei sanktionen sind
weisungen erteilen ist das bafa deswegen
nicht unabhängig nur die gerichte sind
unabhängig wenn sie den juristischen
begriff nehmen wollen
ich verstehe dass ihnen das nicht passt
ist ja auch legitim dass die politische
sagen das passt ihnen nicht aber
juristisch ist der verfassungsschutz
nicht so wie sie ihn beschrieben aber
doch er ist überhaupt nicht ausgewogen
aber gut aber lassen wir das ist auch
nicht das t lassen den verfassungsschutz
das finde ich noch über das
bundesverfassungsgericht geredet haben
das ist ja die höchste ist instanz in
einem anderen land geht das im übrigen
dass abgeordnete als richter in das
höchste gericht hinein wechseln können
die vorher über die gesetze entschieden
haben sie teilweise gemacht haben wir
haben ganz klaren interessenkonflikt
über ihren hart und die ganzen
abgeordneten die ja plötzlich jetzt
richter weiter
also ich muss leider einen kurz
unterbrechen
alu optik und danach sind wir aber
wieder zurück auch weiter mit dem
juristischen beistand von herr winkler
arbeitet ist
[Musik]
also da kann ich ein lauter brauchen und
nicht ernst nehmen als sogenannten
experten
hat sogar meine damen und herren ball
fehlte der 85 köpfen sind meinungen von
jeder von uns hat ein thema mitgebracht
was ihn bewegt freut oder schockiert
so nicht rüber cadbury hergiswil wetten
seit august aber niemand von den
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
diese grün-roten der dar und führen
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
um es nur der dreh zu überlassen lasst
den leuten sondern spaß wir sehen da
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
politik bei den journalisten deren job
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
zu fügen und sie sollen den doch auch
richtig dürfte sein
dass conti zum manko leicht einmal kurz
einsatz behindert werden wir ganz nennen
doch das sind irgendwelche anorak träger
aus abgeschlossen ist ich habe meinen
vater meine sache immer bekommt er
kümmert sich darum niemand gibt sie ihr
denn man muss ja ganz knapp drüber
sprechen das ist einfach nicht fertig
richtig groß die aufgabe von
journalismus einfach die verlautbarung
der politik zu hinterfragen
[Musik]
wir sind zurück und gehen direkt weiter
zur these vom politik chef jan schäfer
die habe ich besorgt eine studie die die
kultusministerkonferenz vorgestellt hat
es geht um das thema lesen und schreiben
und rechnen bei unseren grundschülern
die
besorgniserregende studie hat ein
ergebnis gehabt und zwar dass
beispielsweise beim thema lesen nur noch
44 prozent der grundschüler in der
vierten klasse am ende des schuljahres
den mindest standard erreichen also
diesen den standard den man eigentlich
sowieso erreichen muss 30 prozent
schaffen diesen standard gar nicht das
bedeutet am ende wir haben es mit 14 zu
tun die auf eine weiterführende schule
kommen und ganz ganz viele
qualifikationen die man haben sollte die
man haben muss und die man nicht nur als
mindeststandards am ende haben muss man
eigentlich über erfüllen sollte gar
nicht mehr richtig als fähigkeit erlernt
haben wir können schlechtere lesen sie
können schlecht schreiben sie können
auch schlecht rechnen und es gibt andere
spannende zahlen die wir sehen wir sehen
dass es eine inflation die bei gute
abiturnoten die 1,0 abitur haben sich
innerhalb von 15 jahren achtung
versechsfacht und
gleichzeitig sehen wir aber auf
internationaler ebene sind die deutschen
schüler gar nicht so gut wenn wir sehen
bei den pisa tests beispielsweise nach
dem großen pisa schock anfang dieses
jahrtausends dann halten wir uns
weiterhin so ein bisschen knapp über dem
mittelfeld aber sind nicht deutlich
besser geworden obwohl doch so viele 1,0
abiturienten mittlerweile haben also es
liegt ganz ganz viel schief hier im land
der schuldige ausgemacht meinung nach
das sind die landesregierung das sind
die kultusminister die machen die
schulen kaputt nutzen die kultusminister
und die bildungspolitik als
ideologischen experimentierkasten und
das ist am ende etwas was zu lasten
unserer kinder geht und das darf nicht
sein frau bauer die fdp als
regierungspartei was wird die fdp tun
damit sich das verbessert was sie ja
wahrscheinlich auch wollen also wir
wollen als fdp natürlich des bildungs
und überhaupt unser ganzes
bildungssystem unabhängig vom elternhaus
ist und wir müssen schon ehrlich sein
die letzten beiden jahre mit corona
haben das ganze eigentlich komplett
verschärft auch die zahlen die sie
genannt haben wurden gerade in den
beiden jahren noch mal explizit
verschärft wir hatten erst vor kurzem
zahlen dann aber auch schon 2018
beispielsweise schlicht die waren
schlecht aber nicht so schlecht wir
wissen dass ein drittel der kinder
nachholbedarf hat und eigentlich
nachhilfe bräuchten wissen dass
unglaublich viele junge menschen unserem
land kinder und jugendliche an
psychischen folgen leiden und deshalb
ist für uns als fdp eines klar in diesem
winter darf es nicht wieder zu
schulschließungen zur kita schließungen
kommen denn das ist die grundlage dafür
wir haben in der korona krise gesehen
wie abhängig der schulische erfolg vom
elternhaus ist und es hat sich einfach
viel zu sehr verschärft und ja
einerseits kann eine
bundesbildungsministerin die bettina
stark watzinger sehr vieles öffnung
registrieren ich finde macht sie auch
einen sehr guten job machen wir jetzt
auch sage es ist natürlich nicht nur
ihre aufgaben sondern ganz explizit und
das haben sie völlig richtig gesagt herr
scherer kommen dadurch länder
gleichermaßen in die pedale
beziehungsweise einen handlungsbedarf
die länder müssen ihre aufgabe doch noch
stärker gerecht werden auch ein stück
weit zu gucken was können sie auch
verbessern denn wir haben den eklatanten
lehrermangel wir haben den punkt dass
wir einfach auch im bildungssystem mehr
durchlässigkeit brauchen und wir
verbrauchen auf der anderen seite auch
den zugang zu neueren methoden sei es im
schulunterricht sei es im ev die methode
sind glaube ich so gut auf sie ist
ansprechbar habe die methoden die
methoden sind das problem was nämlich
nicht mehr passiert beispielsweise nicht
weiß das weil ich selbst vater von
schulpflichtigen kindern bin was nicht
mehr passiert ist beispielsweise das
diktate geschrieben werden so gut wie
gar nicht mehr kann man sagen
behinderten einzelfall das gibt es in
anderen bundesländern auch diktate
werden nicht mehr geschrieben wissen
aber auch aus der forschung das
permanente wiederholen der eimer ist
voll das führt dazu dass ich irgendwann
das wort der eimer und voll richtig
schreiben kann und zwar ohne haar und
ohne ai so also das sind dinge da kann
man mal mit methoden kommen noch mehr
technik und alle brauchen ipad es geht
hier glaube ich um wirklich grundlegend
es geht auch um die frage werden noch
gedichte gelehrt nein auch so gut wie
gar nicht mehr werden noch aufsätze
geschrieben ein auch so gut wie gar
nicht mehr also ich glaube wir brauchen
gar nicht viele milliarden zu sagen
jetzt braucht jedes kind ein ipad
sondern wir brauchen eigentlich glaube
ich die rückbesinnung auf das wie es in
der guten alten schule gewesen bin ist
ich bin den 80ern und 90ern zur schule
gegangen da war sicherlich auch schon
nicht alles gut aber möglicherweise war
in den 50ern 60ern vieles was gelehrt
wurde oder wiens gelehrt wurde viel
besser auch ein thema das thema schrift
man lernt jetzt druckbuchstaben früher
hat man schreibschrift gelernt
schwimmübungen es war doch wunderbare
man sich heute schritt anguckt von
vielen menschen von vielen schülern ist
das nicht mehr richtig zu erkennen
dadurch entstehen auch fehler dadurch
sie in schüler ihre fehler selbst auch
gar nicht richtig bedeutet ich würde
gerade sagen die technik ist das eine
das ist wichtig aber den lehrmethoden
sollten wir weg von diesen ganzen
neumodischen zeug und schreiben nach
gehör rückt zu dem was uns stark gemacht
hat also guckt in die alte zeit aber
herr schäfer dürfen sie fragen ihre
these lautet die politik macht und so
schulen kaputt als der einzige nicht
politiker nicht politikerin von ja ich
mache ich jetzt auch nicht als
politische
lager bild wenn ich darf jetzt sozusagen
zu bild und nicht zu den gästen deswegen
nur meine frage und und gar nicht nur
eine rhetorische frage warum ist es
immer noch ein tabu darüber zu sprechen
dass wir weil sie sagen die politik
macht unsere schulen kaputt dass wir
endlich wieder die schul zuständigkeit
dem bund geben warum ist es eigentlich
so ein tabu wäre so grauenvoll wenn der
bund die zuständigkeit hätte sei es
teilweise ganz
aber allein schon einheitlichkeit
bisschen mehr hat ich gebe das
zentralabitur ich hab auch schon das
zentralabitur geschrieben und jetzt habe
ich mal ein um juristische sorge
menschen ganz politisches argument
debatte wenn sie ist verbindlichen also
dem bund geben verstaatlich ist es ja
schon aber wenn sie sozusagen den bund
exklusiv geben könnte es mehr debatten
geben die debatten finden jetzt in jedem
einzelnen bundesland stand weil der
stadt was auch sehr schön ist und
sicherlich auch spaß macht den
politikerinnen und politiker aber wenn
der bund die zuständigkeit hätte für die
schulen dann hätten wir debatten über
solche themen wollen wir das oder wollen
wir nicht wollen wir das abitur so
machen oder nicht wollen wir wieder das
dreigliedrige die system wollen wir mehr
diktate jetzt findet dass irgendwo im
osnabrücker anzeiger stadt nichts gegen
den osnabrücker anzeiger aber das wäre
jetzt mal ein argument sozusagen
demokratie hat sich nicht nur der
osnabrücker es gut haben ja auch
wenn ich mein ich meine ihren stecker
ist der wind politikchef mitglied der
chefredaktion der das thema heute
mitgebracht das ist ja schon ist aber
selten aber ist nirgendwo so etwas
schauen millionen zu sie können mit uns
jetzt hier genau darüber diskutieren ich
glaube übrigens das ist völlig falsch
wäre wenn der bund das übernehmen würde
denn die frage ist ja wer regiert im
bund das sind meistens die parteien cdu
csu spd grüne fdp so und wenn ich in die
bundesländer schauen denn sich ungefähr
den gleichen mix und in den
bundesländern passiert etwas das weniger
diktate geschrieben wenn weniger
aufsätze das bildungsniveau sinkt also
wäre jetzt der gewinn wenn der bund das
machen würde vorher war er und freundin
das sind und vor allem kennen sie denn
eigentlich ein gedicht ich würde jetzt
sagen sie sind ja nicht erst den letzten
zehn jahren abiturientin gewesen ich
habe mir das in ordnung zu sagen kennen
sie noch ein gedicht das mit eben auch
angesprochen ach ja also ich glaube
schon dass ich noch gedichte kenne ich
habe früher viel von friedrich schiller
aber die sind ja sein ich will da im
busch habe ich ihn zu hause gelesen mein
vater hat mich viel wieder imbusch
vorgelesen aber jetzt nochmal zu dem
punkt länder oder bunt es war ja vorher
auch deutlich besser das bildungsniveau
als es auch noch ländersache war so und
da bin ich ganz bei ihnen frau schenk
ich stelle mir auch die frage ist es
denn dann jetzt beim bund besser
aufgehoben kann er das besser
entscheiden also das ist jetzt erst mal
so eine rein administrative frage die
inhaltliche frage die ist recht
interessant ja schäfer aufgeworfen hat
wir haben ja enorme defizite ich meine
was rege ich mich über rechtschreibung
und bei den kindern auf es sind genau
die gleichen beobachtungspunkte die
kinder schreiben plötzlich nach dem
gehör sie werden nicht mehr ordentlich
korrigiert und wenn sie nicht korrigiert
werden das nicht wiederholen kann die
diktate machen dann lernen sie es nicht
vernünftig und das ist etwas also da
werden defizite aufgebaut die sich
nachher gar nicht mehr korrigieren
lassen also ich frage mich wie ein
pädagogisches system das überhaupt
durchlaufen lassen kann also
eigentlich ist doch der erste schritt
dass wir sagen also eigentlich müssen
wir zu den bildungsstandard zurück ich
habe auch ich war auch in den 80er
jahren in der grundschule wenigstens mal
da hin zurück dass wir da wirklich auch
mal so ich sage es mal die
grundrechenarten und schreibschrift
wieder lernen und auch vor allem wieder
diktate machen und auch vor allen dingen
dass die kinder vernünftig korrigiert
werden also das ist erst mal der erste
schritt wo wir wo wir zu rücken müssen
denn ja wir sind auch nicht umsonst
internationalen pisa vergleich das sieht
sich ja vor ort sind wir so weit
abgestürzt also das fängt ja allein
schon in der grundschule anja wir
sprachen über das thema handwerker zu
beginn der sendung auch mit dem hinweis
naturwissenschaften dass es da auch
immer wieder viel zu wenig
schulabsolventen gibt die das eigentlich
als ein kernthema als interessantes fach
sehen und dass da wird der grundstein ja
eigentlich auch schon gelegt wenn der
matte in der grundschule schon nicht
spaß macht oder ich permanente ahnung
habe ich komme da gar nicht hinterher
dann zieht sich das natürlich auch
weiter durch die weiterführende schule
das gymnasium ist oder die realschüler
gemeinschaftsschule wie das dann ja
heute auch häufig heißt und nicht will
das gar nicht unbedingt bei den lehrern
ablegen weil es da glaube ich sehr sehr
viele sehr sehr engagierte lehrer gibt
die mit viel eifer dabei sind aber die
müssen halt dinge in ihren lehrplänen
umsätzen bei denen man manchmal sagen
muss ja ist das wirklich nötig brauchen
wir dass er bewirkt in dem die lehrer
verdienen in deutschland im
internationalen vergleich extrem gute
gibt kaum ein land wenn ich weiß ist
sogar deutschland das land das die
lehrer am besten bezahlt das eis tag ist
das niveau hier schon sehr sehr gut sind
beamte das sind auch gut abgesichert das
gilt dann auch nicht bestellt herr
schäfer ihr vollkommen richtig es gibt
auch angestellte lehrer genau in berlin
hat man jetzt auf die beamten besonders
oder wunsche lehrer verdienen deutlich
weniger als das ist natürlich auch
mittlerweile andere wollen das ist man
kann immer über den über das thema
bezahlung reden das ist richtig deswegen
aber ich glaube das problem ist jetzt
gar nicht unbedingt sind jetzt nicht die
lehrerinnen und lehrer sondern es ist er
das fasten umsetzen müssen was sich in
dem fall dann wieder politiker
ausgedacht haben weil sie der meinung
sind das müsst ihr sein man kann in
berlin und das ist gar kein langweiler
aber ein lied davon singen wir hatten
bis zur landtagswahl im letzten jahr
eine schulsenatorin die wurde ja dann
nachher per gerichtsurteil dazu
gezwungen die schulen wieder zu öffnen
nehmen wir das letzte bundesland was
nach dem zweiten lok da und die schulen
wieder öffnet geöffnet hat und zwar nur
wegen eines gerichtsbeschluss weil die
eltern gesagt es kann nicht sein im
ganzen land wird unterrichtet aber in
berlin noch nicht
argument der senatorin war jedoch nur
noch drei wochen bis zu den ferien wird
da würde sich die schuleröffnung nicht
mehr lohnen so weit sind wir und diese
schule senatoren oder politiker die
machen auch die lehrbücher den lehrplan
des das kann nicht sein wir waren
eigentlich die schulschließung
juristisch akzeptabel
das ist natürlich ein 1 1 sehr vermintes
gelände und und auch ich hoffe sie
begeben sich da ja ich bin mir relativ
furchtlos berufsbedingt aber die
wahrheit ist
und dass die antwort wird sie wird ihr
wird ihnen nicht passen und ist auch
nicht sehr unterhaltsam die antwort ist
es kommt drauf an
es ist wirklich so wir bewegen uns ja in
diesen ganzen corona fragen leider immer
im bereich verhältnismäßigkeit
gefürchtet von jedem jurastudenten von
jeder junge studentin weil es eben sehr
viel argumentation abverlangt weil es
kein schema f gibt und so ist das hier
auch ich merke gerade geantwortet schon
fast den politiker relativ ausweichen
aber ich glaube ist es juristisch
wirklich so die schulschließungen müssen
im einzelfall unter dem grundsatz der
verhältnismäßigkeit
der informationen die die jeweilige
kommune oder das land hatte beurteilt
werden
das war echt ein weil ich bin halt
anteil stellen klar ja ich muss auch
sagen er hat heute in der sendung und am
ende kommt jetzt die große enttäuschung
aber können sie denn als politikerin als
bundestagsabgeordneten mehr als bürgerin
versprechen dass die politik zu diesem
mittel nicht mehr greifen wird und die
schulen schließen wir werden alles dafür
tun ich glaube das ist schon ein ganz
klar dass die bundesbildungsministerin
dieses signal in unser land sendet der
schulen und kitas in diesem winter nicht
wieder geschlossen werden dürfen denn es
sei fatal für die jungen menschen für
die heranwachsenden in unserem land und
vor allem ehrlicherweise einerseits
bezüglich des bildungs aber andererseits
auch den zahlreichen psychischen folgen
die mit einhergehen die gerade in der
auswertung der korona maßnahmen an
signifikanz überschritten haben dass
gerade die psyche schickes auto ohne
auswertung ja gar nicht so ernst
genommen ich hoffe das ist ein ort und
wenn ich etwas überspitzt sage ja auch
noch mehr über hätte ich nach hat kein
hehl daraus dass die ngp nicht immer die
ausführungen von herrn lauterbach teilen
kann und kein fan app kein fan aber
nichtsdestotrotz ist es auch wichtig hin
zu gucken die auswertung hat
stattgefunden ist wissenschaftlich
fundiert und danach müssen wir ganz klar
schulen und kitas offen halten für den
bildungserfolg unsere heranwachsenden
generation aber auch für die psychische
gesundheit unserer gesellschaft denn wir
können gar nicht all diese fälle aktuell
in irgendeiner weise überhaupt in eine
behandlung geben ganz viele in unserem
land fehlen zahlreiche psychologen
landauf landab des kinderpsychologen
sind oder wachsen psychologen auch da
müssen wir uns mal überlegen inwiefern
wir die psychologische ausbildung auf
stärken können gerade diese klinische
psychologe aufwendiges ich glaube vor
allem auch dass sie wieder länder
thematik deshalb auch das was sie vorher
angesprochen haben ist auch viel länder
thematik da bezüglich lehrinhalte
methoden und so weiter und so fort nein
aber wie viele plätze sind denn dann im
masterstudium überhaupt verfügt beim
bayern sind es 100 plätze für die
absolventen aus dem bachelor studium als
100 potenzielle klinische absolventen im
masterstudiengang das reicht aktuell
überhaupt nicht aus und es ist in allen
bundesländern ähnlich und da glaube ich
müsste man auch die diskussion zu
überführen und from power wir machen so
wir sind am ende angekommen sollte es
nochmals schulschließungen geben setze
ich sie hierhin und alle anderen teams
versprochen haben und dann rechnen wir
ab aber jetzt wünsche ich ihnen erst mal
einen schönen abend danke an meine gäste
wenn sie mögen schalten sie doch morgen
abend wieder einen schönen abend noch
[Musik]